okay so here's a cone
um and it's hollow and we're gonna put
some stuff in it in a second okay
before i do that let me tell you some
information about it
um yeah no unfortunately not well maybe
melted ice cream as you'll see in a
second okay so
there's a co what two measurements do
you need to define a cone
you need height okay so i'm going to
tell you it's uh five meters
tall okay and it's radius okay so
uh radius of the base right so i'm going
to give that two meters
okay so there's some um there's some
fluid in here so let's draw some fluid
in
i'm going to yeah
look at how much ice cream this is a lot
of ice cream meniscus
it's like a uh
it's like um i supposed to be like a
factory
or ice cream for giants okay
so here's our code all right and uh
it's actually got a hole at the bottom
okay a tiny uh point
sized hole okay so it doesn't actually
[ __ ] around with the dimensions of our
current which is convenient
and so things are actually coming out
things are leaving the cone at a rate of
0.2 cubic meters every minute
that's all we got okay so
if that's how much stuff is coming out
i'm interested in
this this level of where it's at okay
that's position there okay um it's
obviously dropping
okay so my question is how much is it
dropping
that that level okay and how much is it
dropping
when um that level is actually equal to
a certain position
i think the number i've got is let's see
when there's four left it's actually
quite a bit higher okay so when
that's equal to that's equal to four
how how quickly is it dropping okay how
quickly is it
so i just gave it to you verbally but a
lot of it's on the diagram
what are the how can we set this up what
information have i given you
this is
volume over time volume over time
dv on dt
what are we after
d okay now we don't have anything on
here right so we need to introduce
a variable and if we look after height
okay
a decent name for that would be h
so um i'm after dh on dt
when the height is full
are we happy with that lot of me slowly
if you're happy with that
yeah okay none of you should be nodding
right now
it's like what's wrong there's something
drastically wrong with this
wow things are coming out of my cone and
there's more stuff
ending up in my comb every minute okay
so hold on have a look what are we right
i said stuff's coming out but my rate is
positive
which means things are increasing okay
so this is bogus
right be careful okay this is this is
negative okay now i'm drawing particular
attention to that
right because um it's a classic error
very very easy error to make because you
just look at the numbers you're like the
number's the most important part
and then you go ahead and all the
numbers uh
like you don't come up with a numerical
error until you're at the end and you're
like
it's i'm getting more stuff even though
stuff's coming out it's um
breaking the laws of thermodynamics
anyway okay so
that's what i've got that's what i know
all right
now before i said okay you're going to
have
this being equal to and then you need
the chain rule over here right
so it'll be something over something
okay
so i need to have a dh here and a dt
here okay so therefore what would you
expect is the missing piece
dvd
okay now this step is very crucial to
become important in a second
because what was the thing we did at
this point in the previous question
what did we do
right so we saw we said okay good i know
this bit it's supplied to me by the
question
but um i need to know this bit right
so then you think about okay well what's
the um what's the
equation that relates those two together
okay what is the
equation that relates those two together
the volume of a cone
which is one third
pi uh squared
h it's a third of the cylinder with the
same dimensions
okay now can anyone see the problem
um i want well i guess i want dv on dh
and then i'll flip it
yeah but i don't just have h in there
i've also got this pesky r guy right you
can't ignore him because
h obviously is changing okay it's
getting smaller
but r what's r
there's no r on my diagram
it's it's the radius radius of what
right right okay we sort of said what's
this volume right the volume is the
green part
and it's it's changing as we go it's not
the volume of the whole thing which is
static
okay now if that volume is changing its
height is changing
obviously its radius is also changing
that's r right so just be careful right
because we write an equation like this
without thinking
because well obviously there's an r and
an h but what is it
okay all right now even knowing what it
is you've still got a problem
okay because if you want to
differentiate this um
i need to have it in terms of one
variable namely
the one that i want to differentiate
with respect to h
so what do i do
okay i need to get rid of this r somehow
okay
but i've got some problems i can't just
put in a number
right because the number will change uh
at some point
the number will be two and then at some
point the number is zero and then
there's all these different values
in between okay so r really is changing
i need some kind of variable in there
right so what will i do
um you've got a couple options you could
go for pythagoras if you wanted because
there's a right angle
triangle in here right with the
perpendicular height
the reason why i don't think that's such
a great option to go with is because
i don't know what the perpendicular
height is um i'm sort of replacing
that problem with another one right i
know what this height is
um but it's going to be changing yes so
and i'm going to introduce a square root
into it which is which is a mess
okay i think a better option here is
seeing that as r and h
change this rna change it's actually a
really really simple relationship
between them
okay
r h because this is a cone right are
always going to be
a kind of cone that's similar to the big
coat does that make sense
as my cone gets smaller it's always just
going to be a similar version of the
original code
okay therefore i have some
similar triangles here right um where
are the similar triangles i'm not going
to ask for the proof because this is not
a similar triangle's
proof it's a related rates food it's
this one in here
okay which does happen to be right angle
and this bigger one here
okay which is also right angle okay so
what ratio am i after remember what i'm
trying to do
i'm trying to get rid of r and replace
it with h's because that's what i'm
going to differentiate with respect to
in a second okay so what ratio should i
put down
i want to get rid of ours right so i'm
going to make r the subject
so i want to start with r okay
you know that long thing which you
always hate writing in similar triangles
proofs
about the ratios of science what do you
actually say
you know something over something is
equal to something over something else
because
sorry because what what's the what
what's in here
corresponding sides in in similar
triangles
are in the same ratio right so which are
the corresponding sides
well i'd go short side to long side
r over h okay
should be equal to
two of the five short overlap okay
i suppose i could have written it upside
down but i'm after the r right so this
makes it easy i just have to do one
thing
kick the h over the other side
okay so now i can get my volume
in terms of just h it'll be a third
pi now what's r squared it'll be
4 h squared on 25.
and then i have another h on the end
so tightening that up i'll get four h
cubed
pie i should have put the pie first i'm
sorry
four pi h cubed on 75
okay all right
that was that was hard work to get to
that point okay because i had to
recognize that i had a problem here and
then i had to fix the problem
now what do i do
yeah i set up chain rule before so i've
got all the pieces i need to chuck it
into you okay
do note that it's dh on dv not d sorry
uh this is v so i need to know what d v
on the h is first i haven't
differentiated it
but thankfully it's a pretty easy
function differentiate right
what do i get
yes this three is going to come out the
front because i know in advance
that my denominator is divisible by 3
i'm just going to rather make numbers
bigger and then make them smaller
i'm just going to make them smaller to
begin with yeah so
this is actually going to be over 25
okay and this would be 4 pi
h squared okay you saw how the 3 came
down
all right so now i can put this in it's
the reciprocal so
25 over 4 pi h squared
times uh here we go minus point two
minus point two that's minus a fifth
yes okay so this five is going to
factor into that 25 so i'm going to get
minus 5
over 4 pi h squared
okay now notice if you'd mucked up and
you'd said it's 0.2
cubic meters per minute a positive value
then at this point
you would get a positive value and that
would be the point where you say
wait something's gone wrong because my
thing is getting taller not
shorter okay so we want to add a
particular point now when
h is equal to four so
dht at that point will be minus 5
over 4 times 16 will be
64. and that doesn't factorize so that's
it
now again see here's a really um good
example of what i'm talking about
because you've got your negative there
right
it's kind of awkward really to say
people don't talk in this language
they're like hey how's that how's the
height changing you're like well it's
rate is minus 54
pi you'd say it's it's going lower it's
descending right it's dropping so i
would say
the height is decreasing
at five over 64
pi oh my units meters per minute
so much the same way as we say oh
lengths have to be positive
um rates tend to be positive as well but
we just supply the direction
when we talk about them in natural
language okay